President Trump is expected to address
the shootings in a statement this
morning as he left New Jersey yesterday
to head back to Washington mr. Trump
extended his condolences and thanked law
enforcement chief readers at the White
House ship what more did the president
say about what he is doing about these
mass shootings well in his statement
yesterday he gave no specifics and this
morning a senior White House official
told us this official said he had no
idea if the president was going to offer
any new policies but in a tweet just
minutes ago the president said
Republicans and Democrats must come
together and get strong background
checks
perhaps marrying this legislation with
desperately needed immigration reform we
must have something good if not great
come out of these two tragic events hate
has no place in our country president
Trump condemned this weekend's shootings
but stopped short of calling for
increased gun control perhaps four has
to be done this is also a mental illness
problem in the anti-immigrant manifesto
the El Paso suspect allegedly uploaded
before the shooting he said that his
views on immigration predate the
president Sunday several Democratic
presidential candidates said the
president should be held accountable the
president not only tolerates but invites
the kind of racism and hatred that that
not only offends us but but changes who
we are as a country candidate who Leon
Castro says Trump has given license for
white supremacy to fester as our
national leader you have a role to play
in either Fanning the flames of division
or trying to bring Americans of
different backgrounds together the
president has long made controversial
comments about immigrants they're
bringing crime they're rapists and at a
rally this May a supporter suggested
shooting migrants at the border but how
do you stop these people you can't
there's not
that's only in the Panhandle you can get
away with that step when asked Sunday
about that incident the White House said
this is a time for unity perhaps the
critics could take time out of their
attacks on this president to join us in
that effort
acting White House chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney attributed these latest
shootings to quote sick individuals
people are going to hear what they want
to hear my guess is this guy's in that
parking lot in El Paso Texas and that
Walmart doing this even if Hillary
Clinton is president in his tweet this
morning the president also said we
cannot let those killed in El Paso Texas
and Dayton Ohio die in vain Dana
chip Reid thank you